[تصفيق]
لا تقلق يا صديقي ساضع كل قوتي في يدك
والولايات المتحده تخطط لتقديم هديه
عسكريه لاوكرانيا وكيف تضعوا خطه محكمه
لانهاء الهيمنه الروسيه على السماء
الاوكراني فهل يقبل بها النيتو بينما تظهر
مقبره اخرى للعتاد الغربي في اوكرانيا
وب250 طائره من 25 دوله النيتو يبعث اقوى
رساله في تاريخه لموسكو وبحيله ذكيه الصين
تمد يدها لروسيا عسكريا وصراع الدببه يبدا
في اروقه الكريم
ودول النوويه تسخن اسلحه المحرمه بعيدا عن
الاعين الغربيه والزول السوداني لا يرفع
اصبعه عن الزناد لتستمر اعداد الضحايا
بالارتفاع
مجزره روسيه للاليات الغربيه
دقت ساعه العمل ومقابل كل ضربه اوكرانيه
ستهطل المكافات الغربيه ليدلو كل بدلوه
وبعد ان بدا الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد ها
هي القوات الاوكرانيه قد اعلنت استعاده
اربع بلدات في جنوب مقاطعه من القوات
الروسيه وكالعاده دعونا نشاهد المصدر
الاوكرانيه على اربع مناطق واربع قرى تقع
في ضواحي مدينه دانيسك هذه المناطق التي
تقع تحديدا على نهر
موكرينا واشنطن اولى مكافاتها حيث كشفت
صحيفه بورس شركه تصنيع الاسلحه الامريكيه
تخطط لتسليم كييف خمسه انظمه صواريخ
للدفاع الجوي بحلول نهايه عام 2024 هل
سيصمد الاوكران حتى ذلك الوقت الاجابه
ستحملها طيات الحرب وظروفها لكن مالا
فالبلدات التي استعادتها لا تمثل طبيعه او
اهميه خاصه فهي في حيز لا يتعدى 50
كيلومترا ولا نستبعد انه قد يكون كمينا
روسيا استدراج القوات الاوكرانيه كما حدث
سابقا ولان الغرب سخي امام الاوكران فقد
طمعت اكثر حيث قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
ستطرح موضوع انشاء تحالف جوي خلال
الاجتماع المقبل في المانيا وستتم مناقشه
قضيه تدريب الطيارين والفنيين والمهندسين
الاوكرانيين وبتطبيق عملي من حلف النيتو
حيث بدا الحلف اكبر مناورات جويه في
تاريخه منذ تاسيس عام
بتنسيق واستضافه من المانيا بهدف اظهار
وحده اعضائه في مواجهه تهديد المحتمله ولا
سيما من روسيا وبمشاركه نحو 250 طائره
عسكريه من خمس وعشرين دوله عضوا في حلف
الناتو وشركه لهما فيها اليابان والسويد
الدوله المرشحه لعضويه الحلف لتصل رائحه
المحركات الى انف الدب الروسي وياتي الرد
سريعا ليعلن ان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
لم يحقق شيئا ومجزره المدرعات الغربيه خير
دليل حيث نقلت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه عن
جنود اوكرانيين قولهم ان معظم عربات
المشاه القتاليه من طراز برادلي تم سحقها
خلال الهجوم المضاد وانهم فقدوا معظم تلك
العربات الى جانب دبابات مدمره من
طرازر الالمانيه المضاده للالغام لتنشا
هناك مقبره اخرى جديده للعتاد الغربي في
اوكرانيا ليخرج رئيس الفرنسي مانويل مكون
ويصرح بان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد جاري
وسيستمر لاسابيع بل لاشهر وفقا لما نقلته
وكاله فرانسبريس ومن العجائب في هذه الحرب
ان الطائره لنست المسيره الروسيه قد دمرت
احدى دبابات الالمانيه اثناء التصدي لهجوم
القوات الاوكرانيه في محور زبرجيا على
الرغم من ان هذا النوع من المسيرات ليس
مصمما لتدمير الدبابات ويمكنها فقط ضرب
المركبات المدرعه الخفيفه وكالعاده نحن لا
ناتي بشيء من رؤوسنا اليكم المصدر واشار
الجيش الروسي الى ان عمليه تدمير الدبابه
الالمانيه نفذت بواسطه مسيره الخفيفه
على الرغم من ان هذا النوع من المسيرات
ليس مصممه لتدمير الدبابات ويمكنه فقط ضرب
المركبات المدرعه الخفيفه اكاد لا استوعب
مسيره لا يتعدى سعرها 500 دولار تدمر
دبابه تعادل اكثر من مليونين ونصف المليون
دولار خياران لا ثالث لهما اما ان هذه
الدبابه كرتونيه او ان مصدر الاموال
المدفوعه لها حرام وان تختاروا براحتكم
واذا كان الغرب يحتشدون في كافه اوكرانيا
فحلفاء روسيا لا يغيبون وهاهم يعلنون عن
انفسهم فهنا الزعيم الكوري الشمالي كيم
جونغ اون يبعث برساله الى بوتين ويقطع له
وعدا متعهدا بوضع يده في يد الرئيس الروسي
ومبديا الدعم والتضامن الكاملين بحسب
وكاله الانباء المركزيه الكوريه الرسميه
الامر لم يتوقف عندك وهاهم اصحاب العيون
الضيقه يقدمون دعمهم العسكري لموسكو
وبحيله نكره حيث ذكرت صحيفه
الامريكيه ان الصين ساعدت ايران في تسريع
امداد روسيا بطائرات مسيره لاستخدامها في
الحرب في اوكرانيا واضافت الصحيفه انه بعد
فحص مسيره ايرانيه اسقطت فوق اوكرانيا تم
اكتشاف اجزاء صينيه صنع بكين لم تعلن بعد
وقوفها العسكريه مع روسيا لكن اي خطوه
خاطئه من النيتو قد تجعل الصين تفعلها فما
رايكم انتم وبالعوده الى المعارك على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه
القضاء على اكثر من 470 عسكريا اوكرانيا
وتدميرا نحو 115 مركز قياده وتمركز لقوتك
خلال 24 ساعه وقد تم تداول هذا الخبر في
موقع سبوتنيك كما تشاهدون الان ومن الحرب
الاوكرانيه الى الصراع داخل اروقه النظام
الروسي الذي يتضح جاليا للعلني اكثر فاكثر
ففي خطوه تؤكد هذا الخلاف بدا قدر يسير
عكس الطباخ بوتين اذ اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه انها وقعت عقدا مع مجموعه القوات
الخاصه الشيشانيه المعروفه باسم كتيبه
احمد وذلك بعد يوم واحد فقط من رفض مؤسس
مجموعه فاقنري
التوقيع على عقد ممثل وفي مقابل ذلك سيحصل
المقاتلون المتطوعون على جميع المزايا
والضمانات التي تحصل عليها القوات
النظاميه بما في ذلك تقديم الدعم لهم
ولعائلاتهم اذا اصيبوا او قتلوا وبين هذا
وذاك افادت وكاله بان السويد وافقت على
تسليم تركيا رجلا ادينا بتهريب المخدرات
ودعم حزب العمال الكردستاني فيكفي تسليم
هذا الرجل لتوافق انقره على انضمام ستوكه
الى النيتو
الاحداث والتطورات
اكد المعهد الدولي لابحاث السلام في
العاصمه السويديه ستوكهولم ان هناك دولا
تواصل زياده مخزونها من الاسلحه النوويه
واوضح المعهد في بيان له ان تلك الدول
تشمل الصين وكوريا الشماليه والهند
وباكستان اعلن الجيش السوداني مقتل المئات
من عناصر قوات الدعم السريع وتدمير عشرات
الاليات العسكريه التابعه لها في مواجهات
متفرقه وكانت الرياض واشنطن بشده استئناف
العنف بشكل قوي وفوري في السودان بعد
انتهاء اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار استمر
لاربع وعشرين ساعه بما افادت غرفه طوارئ
جنوب الحزام بالخرطوم بان 18 مدنيا قتلوا
واصيب اخرون الليله الماضيه جراء تساقط
قذائف مدفعيه ثقيله على احياء الازهر
والسلامه فور انتهاء الهدنه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه تشهد نهايه مؤسفه للاسلحه
الغربيه وماذا بعد ايها الغربيون
[موسيقى]